underway right now a march on the las
vegas strip as thousands of culinary
union members want to get back to work
they say they're still not fully
re-employed months after the pandemic
sasha loftus joining us now live near
las vegas boulevard in flamingo with
more on the come back stronger march
sasha
denise this is a massive crowd out here
on the las vegas strip they've been
marching for about 30 minutes now you
can see they're here along las vegas
boulevard right near the bellagio making
their message very clear now they also
want to make clear this is not a protest
but a demonstration that their industry
will come back stronger after 18 months
of pandemic related hardships now
according to the culinary union 21 000
of its members are still not back to
work union reps say they want tourists
to return to las vegas and for
hospitality employees to have their
steady jobs back now the march again
started around flamingo and las vegas
boulevard it's continuing here for a
while longer lots of traffic lane
closures in the area so watch out for
that if you are traveling near here and
of course stay with 8 news now for the
very latest on air and online reporting
live sasha loftis live local now